does anyone else here have anything to
talk about because i don't know you got
any new things to put inside you beside
me
[Music]
hi and welcome back to another episode
of big moves
i've been gone for a long time oh yeah
we missed you i missed you guys too
yeah a little bit a little a little bit
okay right but it's time for it's time
for a live update episode because i
haven't been back since like june all of
july i was out you know talk about your
boobs talk about get to the point
where you stopped
okay fine i haven't seen the girls in a
while because we film once a month and
we're such best friends and we only see
each other once a month
and last month that once a month filming
i wasn't here because i went to texas to
get my boobies redone yeah cause they're
all the best things are in the biggest
things are intense yes
bigger in texas no i actually didn't go
bigger i went the same size but i got my
boobies done in texas things are lateral
in texas
excuse you
her boobies look way better than they
used to okay okay they just keep getting
better that's true yeah it's been a joke
that it's like i have new boobies
they're a month old and now they're
texan yeah
my previous boobs were from l.a they
were super belly girls but now they're
texans yeah
they have different political opinions
than you
they're super racist
oh my god they're the ones who are
liberals they carry guns
[Applause]
i know you have two texans in the room
casey
is her husband behind the camera over
here it was also born in texas where in
texas is casey from dallas oh dallas
okay i was holding it down for they're
holding it down for houston yeah you're
holding it down for h town yeah
anyways so how was that process it was
it was fun i uh so it was fun it was fun
yeah getting your body cut open yeah
because my with my sister it was like a
whole situation i went with my sister
and she took care of me the whole time
and it was interesting like just going
through surgery again because every
you're supposed to get it redone like
every 10 to 15 years it's been like 10
or 11 years
so i got them redone and it's like oh i
haven't been in the or in a long time
and i mean that's what you would
generally yeah yeah true which is good
never be on an operating table yeah so
it's like it reminds me like oh i
remember the last time i was here it was
just a wee lad and you know
wait i have a question what type of
boobs did you get what type of implants
so the first time around i got saline it
was a broke [ __ ] you know yeah
because then saline is the one that you
have to replace with that silicone yeah
you don't so this time around i got the
super high-end like high-tech gummy bear
ones yeah yeah we're twins so they're
called this technical trailer
the gummy bear ones the high-tech gummy
bear ones wait so you don't have to
replace those no they last longer oh
yeah they're more durable they they also
like are they more dangerous though well
no because like they won't if they if
the bag breaks or whatever like it stays
intact like the gel stays intact and
yeah that's what they're doing the whole
thing about silicone leaking into your
body and that's why they were toxic this
is literally like a gummy bear gel like
if it gets squeezed out of the hole it
comes out but then once it unsqueezes it
comes back in so it doesn't like leak
everywhere whereas the saline just it's
how is it
why would saline be dangerous
it won't
leak everywhere that's all so there was
breast implants that were dangerous
though i feel like yeah they were yeah
they weren't they were they were there
so that they changed them yeah but now
they're better at technology yeah i'm
like i'm not [ __ ] crazy because they
know you're not just hurt
toxic okay so mine this time around i
cut around the nipple
and oh wait so your nips came entirely
off no like that's just the bottom line
yeah underneath i thought i saw a
surgery a long time ago where they would
take it completely pop that shake that's
what they're doing um breast reduction
they need to do like a whole like a line
and then like the keyhole thing yeah
wait did you have to break your milk
spout i don't think so all the milk
oh
i just picture like a refrigerator
filter and like you had to break it yeah
yeah yeah and they reinstate it back in
okay so they cut the bottom of your
nipple off and then shove that [ __ ] in
there yeah because they used to go under
the whole boob but now that's how i got
mine i went over the first time around
oh yeah
that's dangerous though right i don't
know that's a dangerous one i'm not sure
this is the best
button one yeah yeah that was the one
that i stopped right the belly button
one yeah so it's really shitty because
like for months and
a week before i had a four months and
then a week before the the surgery
itself i went to their office to talk to
them a day before surgery i had to check
out with them and every time i told them
i was like i really want to keep my old
implants like yeah don't worry about it
like we will don't we'll take care of it
and then you know on the day of the
surgery 15 minutes before i went to the
or i'm like remember doctor i want my
implants he's like yeah we can clean up
and give it to you and they [ __ ]
forgotten they threw it away
what were you going to do like hold them
in a jar i wanted to put them in like
the the the plexiglas
trophy like square thing original item
yeah why don't we on the back of my
screen
maybe i'll ebay one and then the other
like we'll see
you shouldn't have told anybody that
they forgot and then just had fake old
boobies and pretended that they were
yours come on but i wanted like like
someone else's second one and then like
later on left we have to combine the
ammunition oh my gosh
bracelet
necklace that's so funny or like put in
the g4 office and just hide it somewhere
so if someone finds that they win a
prize
we had all these plans and easter eggs
yeah
yeah we had all these plans and they
tossed it out they felt terrible about
it but did they though they did they
they did i feel like they're doing it on
purpose because they're like nah it's
too much work to like
prep it for you yeah and if you put your
old boobs under your pillow the boob
fairy because it doesn't give you money
she gives you a coupon for a free boob
song
i feel like she gives you coupons for
random [ __ ] like coffee creamer and like
some some kitty litter
it's weird
i thought it was supposed to be equal
with greater value sucks
like well you pay for broke tits now you
get broke [ __ ]
coupons
but i am happier with them now like the
shaping is a lot nicer yeah you know so
i'm i haven't even showed you guys yet
are they a regular
post-op post-op photos
yeah i couldn't see the the picture you
showed you were like laying down or
something i couldn't see [ __ ] yeah they
all bruised um the bruising is pretty
much all gone now i just have extremely
tender nipples
like we're not really badged them yeah
what's
but right now it's like it's so tender
that i can't even put a blanket over me
can i click like this on them
that i can feel like it's
they went under the boob right because
the doctor was like you have a great
folds you won't even see it and yeah i
mean it's true unless i those are some
heavies girls
grateful so that's what she said like my
natural my natural breasts had a great
whole bowl yeah anyway um and so yeah
like when i had that like the entire
area bottom half of my boobs were
completely numb
for like forever
like i just recently kind of sort of got
sense back
surprising that you actually feel it
and it's not like
at least like numb for right now a lot
of people don't get it through the
nipples because they're afraid to lose
sensation i was like this is [ __ ] i
got more
what if it dies later yeah it's like it
worth it but i remember when i got my
armpit like
through my armpit i didn't have feeling
here oh like a year
on both sides but just one side
that's so weird yeah
and then it was really funny like i was
hearing stories like the nurses told me
afterwards they're like do you remember
anything about getting put under i'm
like no
um they're like
they're because they were playing
reggaeton because they play music in the
or sometimes
just wants to you know
and so the nurse calls me she's like do
you remember what what happened right
before you got put under i'm like no she
goes well you were laying there and then
you kept telling all the nurses you love
them
and then that sounds like you yeah
and then she goes and then you popped
your head up and you went say it back
so you were just drunk jeanette
i feel like i've had the same
conversation with you did you request
gasolina
totally
totally wanted gasoline and then and
then they're like
before you you pass out you also told us
your favorite song was gasolina because
we were playing reggaeton so i remember
waking up from the first thing i
remember when i woke up from um the
medication was i was sitting on a toilet
leaning against the wall and the nurses
were like you woke up on the toilet yeah
what the [ __ ] that's the first stream of
consciousness and then my nurses were
like honey we need you to pee like
you're you're done but we need you to
pee i'm like okay but i kept falling
asleep every day i didn't give you a
catheter
yeah right
so then i wake up again and i'm like
okay i'm really gonna try this time
and then i was like no it's not gonna
happen they're like we're gonna put a
catheter on her and then they're like
just try it and then they turn on
gasolina for me and they're like try to
dance and pee i'm like
dancing
but i couldn't help like your bodily
functions just shut it so yeah i thought
you would pee
yeah and then so she's like if you don't
pee we're gonna put you in a catheter
and we just pop the catheter in and so i
fall asleep again wake up feel them
spreading my lips and popping a catheter
and then knocking out again it didn't
hurt look i am a huge advocate for for
catheters now i love catheters okay i
had it for two days okay
you were numbed up
maybe yeah but then i was like i don't
feel anything i don't feel like i'm an
advocate for catheters
i didn't have to get up to go pee so my
recovery was just in bed i'm like this
is great for a lazy person didn't kill
me i didn't feel myself peeing at all
and the bag was near my foot so when i'm
peeing i was like ooh free foot warmer
i don't even feel it coming out yeah and
then my sister on the second day was
like hey we gotta they said you gotta
take it out now because you can get a
uti so she said she had to go dump my
pee back god bless her oh my god your
sister did yourself oh my gosh
great care of me wow she was amazing and
then she's like and then you have to
pull out the catheter and she's like i
really don't want to reach down there
and pull out your cat she had to pull it
out so i was like half [ __ ] up he's
your doctor
i was like i was at my airbnb so i was
like i was like how do you do it and
like i'm all [ __ ] up she's like you
just pull it out i'm like okay and i
just reached down there and i pulled it
out i didn't feel anything like you
can't okay you weren't getting enough
drugs you're on drugs so don't say
you're
and then i talked to my doctor friends
like yeah usually it doesn't hurt as
much for women because men's urethras
are a lot smaller yeah no they're longer
and longer too when they get utis it's
like
way crazier than a moment oh you mean
like the the the width the diameter of
it yeah yes so i'm [ __ ] all about it
how do they do you know how they put
them in like what does it look like i
don't know i've never seen
now but i do remember getting like the
the [ __ ] burning feeling in your
urethra after you pull it like after
it's out and then that first pee after
having a catheter is [ __ ] painful
it's like a uci [ __ ] yeah it's painful
is big chilling this is nice i remember
after getting my appendix taken out i
like my whole like abdomen felt like i
just got beat up and like ran over by a
bus and my [ __ ] pee hole was like
hurting so badly
no my appendix oh no but for my breast
implants i don't remember getting a
catheter it was like i went in and like
i left that same day
i don't think i've never had a catheter
or i've never been intubated i've never
had surgery knock on wood is it weird
that i like surgery yeah because it's
like you're improving yourself the way
you want to and also
drugs are great okay cosmetic surgery
yeah yeah
and being put under is super fun
you can also die yeah okay girl you're
pretty much dying and where's the bat in
that might be one right
you ready to die i've been wanting to
talk after this episode if you're ready
to die at least you go out with big tits
you know exactly oh jesus but um
my biggest fear is not dying during it
but i i got my wisdom teeth pulled out
and that was the only time i got put
under but um is waking up while they're
in the midst yeah yeah like i don't want
to wake up and see my body
well that okay so you don't have to
worry about that when you're getting
surgery because they tape your eyes for
that reason
in case you wake up also inside the
anesthesia anesthesia there is a drug in
there that causes amnesia so even if you
do wake up you won't remember yeah
that's scary too
yeah i didn't remember [ __ ] for like two
days and my sister had to tell me what
was going on and i was like i would get
like annoyed at her for something for
not like wiping out my blood fast enough
or something like i'm like sad you're so
dumb
knockout
yeah but she was so sweet like she like
washed my face for me i'm like oh that's
so she did
your sk2 formula yeah like your [ __ ]
10-step career you're like you can't
just step oil
cleanser and everything the funniest
thing though so
um for the first date they put they gave
this they gave us like this breathing
apparatus where i had to breathe and
hold my breath and it pushes up this
ping-pong ball just to make sure that
i'm breathing the whole night and you
have to do it every hour for the first
night my stupid [ __ ] sister her alarm
is brettmann rock yelling wake the [ __ ]
up [ __ ]
every hour
that's hilarious so every hour like i'm
[ __ ] up on drugs and she was sleeping
the same bed with me so every hour just
wake the [ __ ] up [ __ ] and i have to
wake up like sam you're a [ __ ] idiot
[Laughter]
way up
wait did you put that you had a history
of asthma no oh weird because i thought
that was just for like asthma people
because i had to do that when i gave
birth to isaac after having like a
c-section they made me do that ping-pong
thing too oh they were just super
careful yeah yeah yeah that's true but
it was an interesting experience now i'm
in a fight with the airbnb hosts why
because like i got blood on their pillow
and then i didn't know i thought i'd
wash it off like i cleaned it up with um
um what is it uh hydrogen peroxide i got
on their bed sheet a little bit i was
like oh [ __ ] so i got you know hydrogen
peroxide i threw it in the wash
and then um like i threw it in the wash
you know like before we left and stuff
and then
they like
messaged me angry like how could you
like they thought like the message makes
it sound like i [ __ ] killed their dog
oh yeah what kind of morals do you have
to
leave my sheets like this and blah blah
blah like how could you do this what
kind of human being are you i was like
whoa if you were on your period or
something
how is getting blood on a bed sheet
immoral yeah yeah
and then i was like you just charged for
them to be replaced yeah why is this in
a person
it's a [ __ ] bed sheet we could buy a
new one
so and then i was like oh my god i'm so
sorry i'll replace it for you i can
amazon prime it over to you right now
because he sent me pictures of it i'm
like i can replace it for you right now
he goes yeah it's four hundred dollars
i'm like all right suck my dick yeah
yeah the pillow is like yellow and flat
yeah but you don't know who the [ __ ] i
am do you yeah and then so i messaged
him back i'm like it's not 400 bucks my
family works in furniture and upholstery
it's not 400. the blanket was like the
thinnest blanket ever yeah so i was like
how about this why don't you send me a
receipt or a label of the brand that's
on the pillow and they refused to they
didn't of course they escalated to
airbnb instead they're full of [ __ ] yeah
so i told airbnb and i was like
ask them for labels and then so and i
looked up on airbnb it says that linen
stains and whatever it's actually a cost
of doing business and you can't charge
people oh yeah we're gonna get a
replacement but now they don't have all
right
here's the worst part two days before i
came in they're like oh my gosh you know
texas weather we don't know what's going
on but there's cockroaches
and then it was two days before so i
couldn't change my [ __ ] like
why didn't you tell me this sooner it's
not like it's the first time texas ever
had a summer yeah and then i live in
texas and i don't have any cockroaches
yeah
so i was just like my sister was like
you know what it's okay like i'll be
fine with it it's we it's two days out
we can't change anything about it so i
told them i was like you do realize that
i have videos and pictures of
cockroaches and messages of you
admitting that you have cockroaches do
you want to really do this right now oh
my god
you really want to try this right now
like ready to fight
so it's like either i buy you some new
sheets or whatever or i just shut down
so they were just they're projecting
their moral issues like they're the most
exactly immoral people and then like i
took videos and there were other bugs
too ew yeah and then so and then i
looked through their um reviews and one
of them was in spanish like they had
cockroaches and this guy goes what kind
of person would make up lies and these
moral blah blah blah and when i saw the
cockroach's pictures it looks like they
posed the cockroaches
and i'm like let me bring my own cocker
my own model
airbnb hosts light on me like that too
once really oh so annoying so then i
messaged back airbnb i was like okay if
they want to do this here's all the
pictures and [ __ ] of the cockroaches
have fun with that and then i went on my
twitter who's verified now and i tagged
airbnb and then i'm like you know who
the [ __ ] i am now yeah i'm sorry that's
a really douchebag thing to say about it
but it's just like don't try to scam me
out of 400. so then then they send me a
receipt like we went shopping for new
sheets and here it's 200 and like all of
a sudden it's 200 bucks they put those
in their personal house yeah you know
what i mean and then
you're not going to put 200 sheets in
airbnb how do you [ __ ] break but
here's the thing it went from you
damaged these two items so here's 10
items on the receipt i was like stop my
dick dude yeah that [ __ ] good for you
yeah that's good no you were gonna get a
replacement and i get nothing but now i
have like my very first bad review ever
on irene b afterwards oh i hate that
that sucks totally you should be able to
can you respond to it no
yeah
you'll just keep going back and forth
fighting with someone yeah
damn well anyway because i would post
the pictures of cockroaches underneath
the bad review yeah and that's why i
told airbnb and like they have reviews
from months ago saying it's cockroaches
it's not like this is a new thing that's
true
well anyway um let's move on to our
first sponsor here which is doordash
shout outs to doordash i use that a lot
during surgery i bet you did whataburger
what's up baby oh so much it's so crazy
ketchup is my favorite we actually have
that in the fridge
yeah oh damn girl all right so doordash
connects you with restaurants you love
right now and right to your door and now
you can get grocery essentials that you
need with doordash get drinks snacks and
other household items delivered in under
an hour ordering is easy open the
doordash app choose what you want from
where you want and your items will be
left safely outside your door with the
contactless delivery drop-off setting
with over 300 000 partners in the us
puerto rico canada and australia you can
support your neighborhood go-to's or
choose from your favorite national
restaurants like popeyes chipotle
cheesecake factory
water burger
i miss it i know me too water burger
water burger
burger i say i say water burger too yeah
it's just easier yeah things we think of
a burger filled with water
uh okay for a limited time our listeners
can get 25 off and zero delivery fees on
their first order of 15 or more when you
download the doordash app and enter code
mood that's 25
off up to a 10 value and zero delivery
fees on your first order when you
download the doordash app in the app
store and enter code
mood don't forget that's code mood for
25 off your first order with doordash
subject to change terms apply
subject to change that was kind of hard
to say
yes and we'd also like to give a shout
out to our next sponsor lucy which is a
tobacco alternative
if you're still smoking in 2021
sorry
sorry all the shame and all the judgment
i'm an ex-smoker so i can say that
um lucia is a much cleaner alternative
to smoking cigarettes and it's also
better
from what i've read uh than vaping so
let's not do that lucy is a nicotine
company founded by caltech scientists
and former smokers looking for a better
and cleaner nicotine alternative finally
tobacco alternatives that don't suck
they've got nicotine gum and lozenges
with four milligrams of nicotine it
comes
in several different flavors like
wintergreen cinnamon
pomegranate cherry ice citrus or mint so
there's a flavor for any type of person
they're also a fsa and hsa eligible so
you can spend your pre-tax dollars on
them we love that
it's convenient and discreet they can be
enjoyed anywhere like on flights or at
work anywhere on the go a subscription
to lucy comes directly to your door each
month it's very simple you don't have to
leave your house
we all know we love the subscription
delivery services always be there when
you need it it's 20 21 get rid of
cigarettes unplug your vape throw out
your dip get some lucy nicotine gum or
lozenges go to lucy dot co and use promo
code big mood to get 20 off all products
on your first order including gum or
lozenges that's lucy.co and use promo
code big mood at checkout also i have to
give this disclaimer um this product
contains nicotine derived from tobacco
nicotine is an addictive chemical
warning head over to lucy.co and be sure
to use that promo code big mood for 20
off but enough about my perfectly brown
perky new boobs oh my god they're happy
i'm happy she bought her happiness
everyone everyone you can you save money
but you can buy titties
who doesn't like titties yeah exactly
does anyone else here have anything to
talk about because i don't know you got
any new things to put inside you besides
me
is there anything new put inside anyone
else's body besides
[Applause]
i
like by the time this video comes out we
have now announced that casey and i are
expecting yes
and it's so exciting because i mean you
guys already know like and then also
whoever follows our tiffin case channel
know that we did experience a
miscarriage back in april and it was so
devastating because we've been wanting
to have a kid like you know adding to
our family
and
yeah experiencing that was like really
traumatic it was um it was so traumatic
that once we so like we took a month off
to like
kind of just like hold on we got to
figure this out let's go to therapy
let's process this like a month off from
[ __ ] a month off from trying yeah
okay yeah didn't have something i just
wanted
it was like we weren't actively trying
to get pregnant for that month he
stopped treating you like a mom for a
few weeks so for for a week you were a
toaster strudel and yeah
and not a twinkie
yeah you didn't save this journal yeah
you just let it slide yeah yeah that's
great the twinkies are heated outside
the strudels on top oh my gosh no but uh
but yeah so like like i just had a
period i had that fertile week
weren't trying to be active and anything
and then the next month we're like
okay well i feel like we've processed
this um you know we really really really
want to add to our family did it did it
even though you did lose the baby did
the implantation give you hope at least
because you'd been kind of trying for so
long exactly so that's actually
something i didn't mention in that video
on our channel which is the fact that
like the one good thing about that
tragedy is the fact that we were able to
get pregnant and that was what my doctor
told us like you know it's as sad as it
is obviously like you know you get your
hopes up and and like it's really
traumatic to like lose something that
you're so hopeful for and so excited for
it is like
at least you can look at it yeah
physically yeah because you're like the
women like you get attached to it right
maybe emotionally
exactly and then so yeah like the one
good thing is like oh we are able to get
pregnant the first time like after
all these years of being together after
like several years of us being married
and and like kind of loosely trying to
get pregnant
finally getting pregnant it's like okay
well you're able to do it did you do
anything different yes what did you do
different oh you did it from behind this
time
did you lay back afterwards with your
legs in the air to make sure nothing yes
i did that i was kidding but okay yeah
no i did
that don't ask if here you don't if
you're not ready for the answer gina she
bounces so it comes down like she did
that thing you do when you're on the
phone and you're a kid and you just like
yeah
yeah so the different things um were the
fact that okay so in the past when we
were kind of loosely trying it would i
wouldn't really check when i was
ovulating like
when fertile week was
because just a little like in case you
don't know a woman ovulates which means
the egg drops and it could be ready to
be like you know with the sperm like
meat with the sperm and create a baby
that egg is only there for about 48
hours you only have a 48 hour window for
sperm to hit the egg and but the thing
is that there's a whole week of like
fertile week because sperm can live up
to like five days
so if you try to hit like those days
then you can like pretty much have a
stockpile in there ready for the eggs
don't say stockpile and sperm they're
all swimming they're not las vegas
[Applause]
so yeah so then in the past i wasn't
checking when i was ovulating i was like
you know what let's just like i feel
like it's around these days because like
you know i use an app so i'm like yeah
okay
the different things um i started
actually using an lh strip which would
check for this one particular hormone
that spikes when you ovulate so when the
egg is there this one hormone will tell
you like oh [ __ ] yeah it's you're
fertile right now you have an egg there
you better does it give you a bunch of
realization notifications like oh my
gosh get the p and the v yeah how cute
would it be if you made an app where it
sends you a notification like it
pretends that it's like hey i'm outside
can you let me
text you you know it gives it like a
personality yeah i'm gonna leave in 48
hours if you don't pick me up right now
oh he's here okay i'll let you go okay
bye
and i'm gonna leave a mess yeah i'm
gonna let it go
okay um but yeah so those like strips is
kind of like a pregnancy test like you
pee on it and then you get to see
whatever i finally started using those
so then i got to learn my body like
after several months when i tend to
ovulate and then that first time i got
pregnant and also this time i got
pregnant the thing that we did was just
have sex the whole week and just every
day every day we were we're going at it
poor isaac i hope you know he actually
wasn't home okay thank god he wasn't
home and would it matter if he was home
um at this point we're just so like
we you know like we really just wanted
to make this happen so she's like [ __ ]
him i don't care
i mean every adult with the child is not
going to just stop having sex because
they're trying to being loud oh no
[ __ ] yeah
they like the quiet sex too yeah we're
like well we'll be considerate like
actually i don't i don't know if i want
to put this out there in case isaac ever
knows
[ __ ] it um
yeah
it's all
just so happened to be home
and we were like oh snaps you know like
let's get this in uh what we would do is
so on the upstairs we have like this
really long hallway our bedroom is on
one end and isaac's at the other end of
the hallway but in between us and closer
to isaac's bedroom is the laundry room
so we would actually just leave the
dryer running
and it's like super loud
what if casey accidentally gets pavlov
and now whenever he hears a driver he
gets corny
holy [ __ ] that would be everything
he's like yeah
it's time
joke's on you because he was probably
like laundry's on they won't hear me
whole family
me now
at
least huh
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh my god
but yeah that is uh what we did
differently and um
also i guess more pregnancy
questions that i know most people are
curious about i'm due in february
early february is aquarius but late
february pisces yeah it's going to be a
pisces baby
sign with a water sign okay i like that
i like that yeah it's actually uh wait
what's capricorn uh january and end of
december no like the oh uh i don't know
is there an air or area air ground i
can't remember air earth okay because
casey's earth on fire yeah baby's gonna
be water and i don't know what capricorn
is because that's like an earth one and
fire over here
that would be sick if they timed it so
he's born on 21st of september he's a
baby and you guys are earth wind on fire
and that's your song
that would be the most big brain planned
out [ __ ] ever i actually cried last year
2020 september 21 2020 because it's time
i mean what do you mean on that day
though i literally cried i went to
youtube
and i started watching that video
because i was like oh it's you know i
love this song it's september 21st
everyone goes to youtube and watches
this but it was like during the pandemic
and the comments that people were
leaving [ __ ] got me to my soul they
were like
everything's burning down but at least
we have this and then like everyone was
kind of like being like such a community
in the comments of that youtube channel
i was bawling my eyes out because it was
like when you're in the middle of
something that feels
tragic and scary and then everyone's
just on youtube like yo we're still like
humans and we all like the song together
it's like it really is really
it has never occurred to me to go on
youtube but listen to that song on that
day yeah but now i maybe i will we're
going to comment now hey jess yeah we
know you're here crying
every year i refresh and i go like show
newest comments or whatever and people
are all like it's like a little you're a
weirdo it's a scene yeah it's cute
it's an underground scene
yeah actually i kind of relate a little
bit because uh the last day of what is
it april i listen to in sync it's gonna
be may oh my god okay well that's not so
sweet it's not sweet i'm just saying i
relate the fact that every year
and you have your song and she has her
songs my song is better okay
the comments are like we're in a
pandemic but tomorrow's gonna be maybe
and then i'm gonna sit there and cry
yeah
but yeah so
that's congrats
thank you congratulations to casey he's
here too yeah yeah how are you
congratulations on your come
yeah
um first trimester was definitely first
[Applause]
does that trimester man
a boy
i don't know is it wasn't it like the
first time this was really bad it's one
or the other i don't know
but
with isaac i was also super super
nauseous super super super tired
so i guess i know some people can tell
by the way they're caring like if it's
like a basketball it's like a boy it's a
boy but if it's like you get wider then
it's a girl
i i truly believe in that one yeah i
really see yeah i don't really have
vietnamese people think show us your
nothing yeah
how big is it just so you guys know
we're filming this at me being 11 weeks
but we're gonna announce it by the time
this comes out we're like 14 weeks yeah
second trimester okay okay
you have to go on youtube if you want to
see her a little a little baby basically
it just it looks like my stomach it
looks like you ate too many donuts right
yeah looks like you had taco bell yeah
last night that's me on my period i'm
talking about yesterday really
perfect i had a cinnamon you want to see
can i show you my taco bell baby yeah
you know what actually last week i felt
like i had more of a little like
bump but it was hormonal this week came
down it came down you're probably just
eating weird baby's been like doing
doing some dumbbells and seeing your
uterus yeah look at that she's shredding
oh now i can do this tik tok experiment
that i saw for pregnant women they said
that if there's a big heavily pregnant
women woman in your life go behind her
put your hands under her belly and just
lift and then it'll be instant relief
for you or something oh that's weird i
do that with my face
it really does help better no i swear to
god i don't have an effect no no if like
if you pinch it and you pull it away
from your stomach
i can breathe like a full ass breath
i'm like i can't do this
with the pregnancies
pinch it and pull it away from your
stomach
you can like i don't know i have anxiety
and like then i do i think it just feels
good because no it's like a full ass
like that doesn't affect my diaphragm
kind of yeah everything expands so well
you're crazy but in that in those videos
on tick tock every time they lifted the
belly the pregnant women were always
like instant like just melt relief and i
want to know what exactly is going on so
when that happens i need you to explain
to me what i'm going to do
well there's like there's also like
pressure on your bladder oh
when the baby's like that big
first trimester symptom is also peeing a
lot because there's like more blood flow
going down there
so
every night i've been waking up in the
middle of the night to go pee and it's
so annoying because i'm like oh man the
baby's not here yet but it's already
like annoying training me to wake up in
the middle of the day you need to get
back into work mode you can't be lazy
catheter advocate over here
you don't want to get out good
just here you go
there you go
no but i don't know i end up like
turning a lot i thought it could pull
out it would it'll be like that you'll
be fine we'll anchor it on one corners
you'll be fine
yeah yeah whatever just get casey to
empty the bag yeah
it's lovely does he really love you does
he really love you
yeah
um
it's like craving stuff like i totally
have been craving and then what have you
been craving the most
i haven't had one thing that's been
consistent it's been it's been [ __ ]
weird because i'll i'll really love a
food one like one day and then the next
day or like the next week i think about
it and oh my god it makes me want to
vomit
it's [ __ ] weird it's like when you
drink too much vodka and then the next
day you smell vodka and you want to and
you want to vomit but last night it was
fun yeah or like i won't even get to eat
the thing i was craving but then i'll
think about it the next day you know it
makes me want to throw up
it's really weird also scent like sense
yeah um like strong smells would trigger
my gag reflux but
because right now
because right now in the 11th week i'm
getting closer to finishing first
trimester which means my nausea has been
a lot better
um
i don't feel as tired anymore because
man oh man do you feel tired in the
beginning because you were tired anyway
before the most part yeah that was
because like a depression too
right yeah that happened that whole
thing
yeah
but yeah so i've actually just been
spending a lot of time like sleeping
taking naps and then because of the naps
i'll end up staying up super late like
i'm like up till like 3 a.m i'm like
[ __ ] my sleep's all [ __ ] up dang but
it really is training me for when the
baby comes yeah and it's gonna be your
schedule also i'm gonna be a water baby
so i'm gonna be very emotional and i'm
gonna demand your attention oh my god
last night it was so weird because our
cat always sleeps with us maya she
always sleeps with us in the bed and
she's always purring and everything but
last night her purring was like i i
could not stand it
i couldn't stand it i'm like she needs
to get off the bed oh my god what the
[ __ ] is happening why is it like a
sensory overload yeah yeah yeah
what in the world that's weird because
it's just like yeah
yeah and i'm like oh it's so loud
smells are amplified sounds are
amplified probably brightness will be
amplified yeah this is really not
selling pregnancy for us well done you
know what was crazy
a few weeks ago earlier in the pregnancy
my sound was all [ __ ] up like i
actually couldn't hear people speak if
there was like multiple people talking
mm-hmm and i was like what the [ __ ] am i
going deaf this is a weird pregnancy
symptom wait so it got like muddled or
it just got low okay it got muddled like
yeah it was just like all the sounds
kind of got combined and i couldn't make
out what people were telling me like
saying to me that's weird okay so i get
sensory overload just like in life and
that's exactly what happens when there's
too many sounds like when too many
people are talking at once like if i'm
at a table and there's too many
conversations going on i get so
overwhelmed and i try not to like let it
show because not because most people can
handle that but i totally get that
feeling like it just sounds like and
someone will be talking directly to me
and i can't like understand what they're
saying because there's too many
conversations going on around me yeah
now i know what that feels like yeah
i've never experienced that before
that's why i would cry on the club too
because there were way too many sounds
and noises and like lights
and like
there's a meme called why am i crying in
the club right now sensory overload
that's why
that's so good
yeah the last thing is a lot of people
are at like have been asking us like our
friends and stuff what what are we gonna
have like do we know yet like the sex
and we decided we're gonna wait until
the baby's born
selfish controversial selfish i wanted
to buy any [ __ ] no yeah we'll buy stuff
but i could be gender neutral yeah like
neutral colors but the the route like
the the theme or whatever that i would
absolutely love but it's really [ __ ]
hard to find in baby products is just
like black white teal and red oh but
like your house
yeah actually
yeah like our house because red is his
favorite color teal is my favorite color
but it's also like kind of neutral yeah
and then white and black just looks
really good against those colors like it
has to be like a particular tone it's
probably stuff on like etsy like
probably that you know the big chain
stores might not have as much but i feel
like there's like indie brands that
probably have those because i've seen it
i've actually seen one on shark tank
that had that kind of like indie vibe
you mean you don't want to do a gender
exchange where we can start a forest
fire a gender exchange i may exchange a
reveal
i would love to hear your genders
you should go and start your babies make
some more money
i don't know where that came from
anyways back to forest fires no
i'll consider it it could be fun thank
you for me
burn down the rest of l.a yeah but then
we'll and then we'll go watch that
september 21 video yeah
and comment the world is burning but
they won't know we did it yeah
well thanks for stealing my thunder
anyways uh yes
sorry boobs
what do you want up to jess have you had
anything inside you lately
i don't know i think what i could have
inside of me though is some candid clear
aligners yeah
actually i i mean i have perfect teeth
so i don't need them but i'm here to let
you guys know that if you do need if you
do want to achieve that perfect look
if you want a perfectly straight smile
as well as a white smile candid can help
you thousands of people have used candid
they're clear comfortable removable and
practically invisible liners to help
straighten teeth your treatment is
prescribed and closely monitored
remotely by the same life licensed
orthodontist from start to finish while
other companies use gentrol
general dentists
i can't help but laugh because you're
always so perfect i know
your perfect teeth can't make perfect
words huh
maybe need some aligners yeah
i need a tongue aligner
while other companies use general
dentists candid only works with
orthodontists who's who are okay you all
gave me like the oho of the map i'll
give you a complex candidate
what's that called is there a thing for
that
i don't know it's the
i the evil eye thing of the mouth yeah
and it only works with orthodontists who
are experts in tooth movement you can
book an appointment at a candid studio
near you or do everything from the
comfort and convenience of your own home
and the average can of treatment is just
six months you could have some beautiful
teeth in just six months or and then you
get to see results sooner than results
yeah pretty fast actually and it costs
thousands less than traditional braces
and with your aligner treatment you get
candids teeth whitening full
fell free canon can help you get
straighter brighter smile you've always
wanted right now you could save 75 on
candid starter kit go to candidco.com
mood and use code mood that's
slash candidco.com and use code moot you
take code
take advantage of this limited time
offer to save 75 on your starter kit
candid co.com
mood code mood nobody has time for
braces and you know what else no one has
time for your [ __ ] uncomfortable shoes
not
cursing this out
[Applause]
tiff your feet are going to swell up
soon that means you're going to make
you're going to need some really comfy
shoes yeah i'm so happy i have my
rothies yeah
shout out to our sponsor rothys they're
so comfortable these shoes are
comfortable not only are they
comfortable but do you know they're made
from like recycled water bottles like
they're they're very sustainable
um they come in all different styles and
colors you can start summer off on the
right foot
comfortable bestsellers like flats
loafers and sneakers i have sneakers in
there
so comfy they're like having a sock on
your face yeah it's very soft for
plastic bottles yeah
i don't know how they did how do they do
that i know they also recently launched
men's shoes that are durable washable
hello men wash your shoes stinky toes
and created with nearly zero waste
i
just i wear them everywhere it really
feels like my feet are protected but
they also are in like an enveloped sock
it's soft on the skin and they're cute
rough yeah yeah a lot of shoes are rough
on the skin these are soft on the skin
exactly it feels nice plus the style i
don't know i got the kind that it
reminds me of like a 70s like vintage
tinny look it's got like really cute
colors anyway
uh step up your summer wardrobe with
washable sustainable stylish shoes and
bags from rothy's head to rothys.com
big mood to find your new favorites
today that's r o t r-o-t-h-y-s
dot com slash big mood
[Music]
yeah what you've been up to jess i don't
i haven't been up to not a goddamn time
i know what you've been up to you had a
little you had a little um
vagina pitter patter what
oh yeah
she had a little pit pat in her chair
down there
[ __ ] was gonna come out
i was actually gonna ask about your your
group that the like by the stream or the
lights
the dog park group i've never seen them
because they've been doing a lot of
construction on our apartment and then
the dog park was like locked
for a while so i was like okay well that
kind of killed the steam off of that but
yeah what about your pitter patter yeah
the parts work everybody i think i
really wanted this while i was
recovering i just woke up looked at my
chat and just knew and i was back to
sleep
and her vagina i texted them because uh
at like two in the morning or something
i went out um so in austin there's this
like row of bars that are all outdoors i
think one of them is called like
moon tower another one's called like
lucy's or i forgot what it is but
there's just like a whole string of like
outdoor bars so it feels more coveted
safe because they're huge properties and
so it's like very socially distanced and
it's also outside so like that's what
the only kind of place i'm i'm not sure
i'm vaccinated but i'm not super
comfortable going in a club or anything
like but they're actually there's a lot
of people there and it's really fun and
they play games there like corn hole and
they have like there's this bar has like
hula hoops and like
ping pong tables and stuff so i'm just
activities an activity
bar but it's super chill laid back
um so i
walked in with my friend and we were it
was like a birthday party for this girl
that i didn't know but it was my friend
that lives in austin she's introducing
me to new people and one girls was her
birthday but we were there with like a
picnic table full of people but as soon
as i walked in i was like oh that guy's
kind of cute and i kind of locked eyes
with him for a second i kept going and
then just
i went through i kept continuing walking
through got to the bar we did took our
shot or whatever and i went to the
bathroom and i was looking in the mirror
and i was like
hmm
like i kind of like he was still in my
brain even though i just walked past him
and then we sit down and we
well first we were playing a little game
or whatever and i kept kind of like
looking over and then we finally pick a
table and guess what they picked the
table right next to his table
and i was like kind of sitting in front
of him opposite of him so we were
basically facing each other on opposite
picnic tables and in my head i was
starting to think like my vagina hasn't
felt anything in 12 months
but it's starting to feel something
right now it's getting resuscitated yeah
yeah and um so yeah
basically i once i pointed it out to my
friends like that guy's kind of cute i
kinda like that guy he's like pretty hot
but i was like i'm not gonna do [ __ ]
because i'm not trying to date right now
i'm not gonna like put myself out there
whatever and so and then she was like
she was gonna embarrass me if i didn't
like do something because she's just
like you i want you to date i want you
to date blah blah blah or something like
she's like trying to push me and i was
like don't [ __ ] embarrass me don't
[ __ ] embarrass me and so anyway she's
like okay well let's just go play
cornhole so we went to go play like
right next to them as they were playing
like literally at this like i don't know
the stall right next to them we were
right next to them and she was like
purposely throwing the [ __ ] bean bags
like to almost hit him so he would have
to like bend over she's a good friend
give me the
good wingman yeah yeah and but she was
throwing like [ __ ] so like basically the
guys kind of almost stopped and was like
trying to help her because she was
starting so bad and everyone was like
hey just try it like this but she was
like yeah yeah sure you know just like
tossing them like not giving a [ __ ] and
just like making them go everywhere so
that the guys were like helping us pick
them up
and like so we were kind of talking like
but not really just like
yo you're next to me like how funny like
oh here's the thing oh thank you
whatever like so i was kind of speaking
to him sort of but then his friend was
kind of like
trying to talk to me more and then he
like goes to introduce himself to me
like what's your name and then i got his
name and stuff and um so i was like oh
[ __ ] like i think his friend might be
like trying to talk to me too much like
i'm kind of interested in
this guy but then why is his friend like
the one that's like giving me the
attention i was like i didn't kind of
want that to happen but anyway so i
introduced myself and i was nice or
whatever but
i forgot to introduce myself to the guy
that i was like eyeing the whole time so
i totally [ __ ] blew it like my my i
guess my chance to me meet him
officially or like continue the
conversation i was just like oh what's
your name oh dale whatever yeah and then
i just totally [ __ ] ignored him and
then like kept playing this [ __ ] fake
game of course
fell flat on my face basically but um so
i don't i feel like that was probably
rude so he was probably like okay like
you introduced yourself to my friend
standing next to me but you didn't
really you were just so shy
and i was like okay yeah like i i get
like i haven't i don't know i i usually
don't give a [ __ ] about like
guys having to be the one to come up to
girls but like i get it like it like
when you're really kind of infatuated
with someone in the moment it can be
hard to like go up to someone they're
way more intimidated by you
i guess yeah but i mean i i get i get
the feeling though because i like i
totally face palm like i we went over
there for that purpose and i and i
totally didn't so we go back to the
table and the girls were like oh sorry
you struck out i was like yeah
you're like jokes on you i didn't even
try all right
i need to pick up the bat yeah yeah i i
like handicapped myself on purpose but
then yeah and then his friend again
later comes by and he's like do you want
a drink and i was like i was like no i
don't want you i don't want to talk to
you i want to take your friend
but friends are the gateway they're the
guys i know but like
like way to be like oh well how about
your friend like does your friend want
to get in trouble i know but that would
i wouldn't want to be that forward right
to show that i'm obviously interested in
his friend like because that's that's
just a little too much for me right now
to be like oh i'm interested in your
friend like what's up with your friend
i didn't want to do that and i also
didn't want to like start talking to him
and like take his drink if i'm not
interested in him so i just kind of like
voided myself from the situation but
there was a couple times where we were
sitting across the table and he caught
my eye and caught his eye and my [ __ ]
vagina went into my throat
but yeah so i just i obviously i'm not
ready yet and it's on august 15th which
i think this comes out after yeah august
that will be a full 12 months of zero
peen and vagine wow
so i'm fully
virgin again yeah you reversionized
yourself i'm re-virginized and i don't
know i just you've done it before girl
you've been a whole year without sex
before no
i mean what so like when me and my ex
were together we would say that a lot
but we would still have sex like within
the year it just wasn't often yeah it
was like maybe seven months or six
months i thought that was crazy but a
whole year but this is an actual year
like no man in my life at all and it's
actually pretty good and you haven't
really been having those feelings at all
until like this yeah so i was texting
them drunk basically
later on that night i was like oh my god
my vagina is in love it's like
oh you did say love you like love and
then and then i put an asterisk and i
put sorry lust um yeah my bad because i
don't even know his name
chemical connection yeah but and then uh
this other girl that that was there in
the party she was like i'll help you
let's just [ __ ] go over there you
know like if all the girls go over there
yeah you know then it won't be so
obvious that you're being so forward but
i was like move as a pet yeah yeah yeah
she's trying to help she was doing her
best they were all trying to help but
yeah i was just like no but also i feel
like you know looking at him he has
tattoos and like he's just the wrong
like i'm judging about that
i definitely make it excuse me also like
his group was like a really weird group
i was like i don't know if this is the
right kind of guy but he's really
[ __ ] hot but his group is really
strange like i don't this the whole
strange about them they were just such a
weird mixed bag of people
i was like i can't figure out who this
guy is like i don't know i was just it
was um the whole situation felt unclear
to me i was like his friends are all
[ __ ] like such a weird mix yeah you
need a predictable guy yeah i need a
predictable guy with no tattoos so right
now a [ __ ] nine-to-five job like once
you start getting into the dating world
your
mission is like i'm not i'm not trying
to [ __ ] around anymore like right yeah
no [ __ ] round i've done all my hoe in
i'm cleaning my soul out from the whole
phase
and it's very just directly this is
dating for marriage or whatever for long
term and so i don't want any more like
i'm gonna just [ __ ] this guy because i
haven't had sex in a long time like
personally i don't have a problem with
anyone doing that i've spent most of my
20s and 30s doing that
i'm just not doing that anymore so even
though my vagina went into my throat for
that guy i wasn't gonna like throw your
make it happen or whatever because he's
probably growth girl i got you i got the
feeling that the universe didn't want me
to be with him it was a test right but
and so i was just like oh he's hot as
[ __ ] but no i don't need that
i need like a i need a straight arrow
type of guy
you know a little soft maybe all right
jogging around the rich neighborhood
not necessarily rich but he needs to be
like a little more boring and
predictable
you know not going to
lose all of it
boring predictable
and that's when i met brian yes right
my whole life i've had crazy mother
[ __ ] i want zero of that
i want absolute boring men you can have
a balanced no
i'm gonna go out and talk to guys and
whoever is so boring that puts me to
sleep i'll give you his number yeah yeah
please want to scout him out please too
yeah i have a couple accountants in mind
yes yeah i'm like i'm like yeah that
isn't early i'm just gonna go back to
work to find a boring husband yeah yeah
there we go
or something
[Laughter]
um okay so i just launched another
collection from a jewelry line the
highlight collection although by the
time this comes out it'll probably be
gone but we will be launching more it's
just not the same stone every time what
are you calling it the what the how
light so the what the [ __ ] is that is
that a stone name yeah the stone that
one yeah so that's the stone that jess
is wearing in her necklace
like marble kind of looks like marble
you know like
like in in hawaii they call it
yeah that's like really offensive no is
it isn't it like you look at the hallie
over there
right here
the how light uh yeah that's the stone
that we decided to relaunch because it's
really pretty thank you
you're really pretty thank you so um
each i don't have it on and i keep
acting like i have it i haven't made my
ears but we had earrings and necklaces
and they're shaped like cat heads but
they're just really simple jewelry with
the stone as like front and center and
each stone has its own meaning if you're
into that if you're into like crystals
and stones and meanings i just like them
as reminders so
um we're doing really limited stocks of
each of the stones and it'll be the same
concept with the cat and the crystal in
it but just a different stone each time
and so once that stone is sold out it's
gone forever
um we'll never release that stone again
but there'll be new stones that come out
like every other month or so
and it's just really exciting like
putting everything together because this
is the first time that i've really
felt the ownership over putting out i
guess merch it's not really merch
because it's a whole like line but um
the first time we launched this jewelry
line in 2018 it was just a company like
handling it i was like a third party
company just like when people do
youtube or merch or whatever you just
like tell them your ideas they have
their designers that you approve it and
that's that this is like very hands-on
like where i'm handling like most of
everything and um they send me the
samples but like i'm helping design and
i hired a graphic designer and like
there's a whole mix of things and it's
it feels like my it feels like my baby
like a little baby and um well i want to
get to the point eventually where we're
releasing at least something every month
and then maybe multiple things per month
but it's always just like limited stock
campaigns um at least
for the next foreseeable future we do a
lot of uh cute stuff coming out though
i'm like so excited i don't know how
long it's gonna take because each step
has taken a little bit longer than i
initially anticipated
but especially with shipping delays
because of the new covid
but it's been really really fun and then
i've had a lot of fun on the little
photo shoots i had my friend jess she's
really good at taking pictures
other jess um and i hired her to be the
photographer for everything and the
photo shoots have been really fun yeah
they're really cute putting together the
photo editing and like putting together
the instagram feed if you go to at kits
underscore and underscore cough
that's the instagram and yeah it's just
a little like nugget but it's growing
and it's really fun to see it grow and
i'm learning a lot along the way and
then i've balanced that out with uh if
you've been watching my daily vlogs on
youtube.com i watch them every day
thanks gina yeah we're doing vlogist
right now
there's another one like vlogmas so
there's vlogmas and then we did vlartch
and then oh that's so so you just really
wanted to make it work i do not like
what you're doing
i was kind of making fun of it yeah i
was going to do blue live it was too
close to large so i was like okay
vloggers or vloggers
that's [ __ ] funny
yeah so i've been uploading every
weekday throughout august and i've been
just like updating people what i do on
my daily life and it's a lot of jewelry
stuff in poker i've been doing like a
lot of poker and not just like being a
degenerate and gambling every day but
like learning all of the poker math
doing it right workbooks like yeah like
doing the nerd way doing it the [ __ ]
nerd way like the counting cards yeah
like
buying solvers and like apps that show
you frequencies of hitting certain
health cards on certain flops and on the
percentage that you'd be up against a
different hand that would beat you and
just a lot of that and then applying it
with poker games so i will play like
a real game like two to three times a
week to to see if i've improved or if i
have like if i can use any of the skills
that i've learned or the strategies i've
learned because it's not just the math
part there's also the strategy part and
then there's the psychology part like
actually playing a live game is
different than playing ais that are
programmed to play like people um like
you have like people that make terrible
decisions you have people that have tell
um yeah that [ __ ] talk that you have
like a lot of psychological aspects uh
but basically you're just trying to find
people that are playing worse than you
and then you take advantage of that in
their weak spots and it's really been
cool to see like how much more obvious
weak spots are when you know what you're
looking for
um so yeah i've been having a lot of fun
with the strategy part and so far i've
been
running hot so nice that's that guys
that's what's going on in everybody's
life thank you for tuning in go be sure
to follow us on instagram you know like
casey's been doing all the like these
little reels of snippets of the show you
can share them with friends it really
helps the show out and they're done
really well i really we really
appreciate you casey i hope you guys are
great baby um and then also check out
our sponsors anyone that we've mentioned
on the show if you just let them know
that you've found a found them through
big mood that helps us a lot and write
us on itunes and all that jazz and we'll
see you next week we love you love you
bye